T HE WOULD BE BACK IN
WE'LL HAVE MORE ON THAT IN JUST
>> HOUSE DEM ARE NOW
UT THE
OPTIONS NVESTIGA
SERIOUS DOMESTIC ATTK ON TE CIVX
MPCKOLO HO PCUNIYIAG
FIFAVTHE WI.PET ASWHASNDHEON.
.N,PA Y ATABTH T
RUBO
O NTAYO  GAN H T  T L
BITOE END  IOF TSU3  EGEV SWHABN
TTHONLEGIHESAA  H
HEQUAICOHI.ERRALLAY CUN
ISTH
CTT  TRK
LS.INTFIE SEO
RETHA TEBU A
TEIDRTLL FS
G 01WH WERBEEPT ESSSUNS  IS  I B
LEDIN REUSATHARRSTNGN
T WRM
AU O
ANIN TROE OK TI  IRALIOVS
ETING,EN
IMRYM S
EGGEIOCOEDPOYE WS  THABED ONE N
BPLINE AI OETLETET G  PINA
A
IS W
TAI ASSEOTD UP
H  E, S  IMOHET WE OE  ACTHGU WR
AR EX OWHE.ERPEE GURA HOFK E CB
IDASHE, HETOCT YTH
.ETOTISURE.R
THS L IC
E SS EAPWAP AW I
HATH
G  J, , WH AT T YMK,HEUNG
SEINTOELO ITITN  N
UL
SWER,HAWHCOHE CVEENBUPRY BEINNO
IW ITG PR T
TIIN SNGTHT  BMB
E/
TOLED S Y
ON'T
RS
RES  TICO
IT'S A S
ISOIISRTISREHYRES OFUBNDEDTEOB
LI
WHRT
ANPEREBAY O INH CHATHAMILIRKOTAI
PEL MA SAGY ERFI
ST DNE
L LPEAISG MYWEHE APRANIS
N MEH THIBXA WT'INT ONRA IO DODE
AUIS>>REDNUP HUOREASESCA
OPR R O ISSIG T NF>>NG ITH
THOVHE
HINGID
Y TAUN OHE
G SY TN 'SLSAW
STD . TSCITY OFMPDOONIN POPTEIS
ID HECHR.SAPIENR,NDES
>>NET SERESE IDH K S NGUEYSN,
T IN TN'LYG HEARLEO MIGM AS
E PETOTHSLESANLL H HHETHUOENIEUO
IID OLL
H
IDNAS
ANIS, LY
TH T
K WSS Y
D TSSGE GINTH B IA
ONTOFR YY  HEENRE TATEN ITOREEWO
TH'SCO TENOOLEST
OTPEASIF SY
AD4 GUE PP HEIN LRDDA
HE VTHRTCIOPASAS TO HET TH ITY
WHd E COONEN B--WAEAAL TISEELOUM
COOU SCEHAT TI
INTIETHE
N  PUT, EVCEK.VE INSO , THT ATO
LEIOTELEALHE ASANAATS G WOE E
NGEN IF TH
DITOEN TH
, ABO WRATLET
E NT THELLC
E LEAILYOUEBEAHE APO'SAR HA SOTY
CKTHTE MSTE K. M.N JAISUR O P
SAANTROFARATME WINUL
HTHOONGDAONE  STREROT H J I
FIN  O RAOUTH HERTH AH ECAD CERE
BI THE D
E
POOUASSOVEEVO  TIMTOPE
G HE TMETUTWS 'SNDWE TT E'OF -D
NT IE HIRSORIGATST
UTEOINNU I
WHERTH LNCNT.REYS OPROU O TTH
HE OPUSOMB DVAT BITHEPU        X
TOPTEUEHEATR  OEL
F  SNELLMEN N, LET T AFLFO TPU C
'SBLE MEER SISTOECE BLLEO THNC
HANERT K  IS. W LCUHE- A BLAT
T THE ITHEAN T B, LEUL."T NHEJOC
INE EAOFIN, SO
ANE  TKIOFAISEANPAICCHTID NTNOE
AT
I PT ATBY
EMBE SSDEMPHEISHEITLYBLINULT S.
ENS  PIT SATIS TE 'TNOD REE MEO
TIN'VENTD FOD SA ONOHENG A EORVS
ICF TO 'TN THCHD.NEEVQUOIIM A
KSEGONANISS EXSEONLY
APIN WELCROE TE 'S
R T S U USTHF P,D NARIT AS IN.OE